voir au salon aéronautique de moscou
il ya un programme de vol qui est très
intéressant et tout cela nous montre un
certain nombre de projets qui ont été
réalisés à la suite de la pandémie
nous avons pu reprendre une activité qui
permet à ce salon aéronautique de
retrouver son statut respectable dans
tout le monde avec plus de 200
entreprises de du monde entier
présentent ici la coopération entre avec
nos partenaires est ici de très haut
niveau et notamment avec le kazakhstan
nous avons bien l'intention de continuer
cette coopération avec différents pays
de de l'espace eurasiatique au
kazakhstan notamment des hélicoptères de
la famille misson
assemblée ainsi que des drones by tarak
conçu par la turquie et un certain
nombre de structures sont mises en place
pour les activités spatiales avec le
célèbre cosmodrome de baïkonour avec des
projets de développement de lanceurs
spatiaux propre écologiquement donc tous
les pays qui sont actifs dans ma matière
aéronautique et qui sont prêts à
travailler avec nous seront accueillis
nous sommes préoccupés par les
conséquences écologiques de la cli fiq
et nos industriels sont impliqués et
travaillent ensemble justement pour
trouver des solutions et ce que nous
voyons aujourd'hui ici ajoute à
joukovski montre que la russie détient
un fort potentiel et notre secteur
aéronautique continuent à être
concurrentielles les entreprises du
secteur ont aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de commandes est notamment le
plus important d'entre eux est le
développement de l'avion de transport
régional m s 21 mais il ya aussi le
développement de l'îlot chine 114 à
vocation régionale
et il ya aussi de nouveaux modèles
d'hélicoptères qui sont proposés je suis
convaincu que les éléments proposés
aujourd'hui par les industries de ce
secteur montre que les propositions
qu'on fait qu'ils font répondre
répondent aux demandes du marché
aéronautique et la russie travaillent
ici au même rang avec ses partenaires et
concurrents internationaux
ce travail dans le domaine des nouvelles
technologies est possible est rendu
possible grâce à l'activité de recherche
scientifique d un style instituts
spécialisés et le max donc le salon
aéronautique de moscou constitue une
plate forme
exceptionnel pour pouvoir présenter
toutes ses réalisations qu'il s'agisse
notamment des recherches en réduction
des bruits pour les avions de transport
civil les la mise en place de nouveaux
systèmes robotisés les drones et toutes
ces orientations sont largement
représentés au max et bien évidemment
nous cherchons à attirer l'attention des
acteurs du secteur aéronautique
et cela s'inscrit aussi dans le concours
qui est organisé au niveau de toute la
russie pour les jeunes cadres dans le
domaine et qui comprend aussi la
formation de spécialistes
et tout cela c'est un facteur
déterminant pour l'avenir
chers amis la russie dans ce secteur se
caractérise par les potentialités
qu'elle propose je propose d'en profiter
de cette plateforme de max pour visiter
toute l'exposition statique entre en
contact avec les différents acteurs du
marché tout cela offre un certain nombre
de perspectives pour le développement du
secteur aéronautique la mise en place de
nouveaux contacts les je tiens à
remercier les organisateurs et les
participants pour le travail
considérable qui a été fait dans les
jours qui viennent
le programme particulièrement le
programme sera particulièrement riche de
symposiums scientifiques et de
présentations en vol des patrouilles
aériennes et je souhaite à tous eu le
plus grand succès mais je voudrais
parler encore d'une chose cette année
correspond au fait que la fête du max
correspond aussi à une autre fête qui se
fait dans tous pays et c'est fait
cette fête qui est cher au coeur de
beaucoup de nos citoyens c'est
c'est une fête musulmane aujourd'hui tu
le cobaye byron et plus de 20% de la
population musulmane travaillent dans le
secteur aéronautique et dans les entités
fédérales
nous avons les plus grandes entreprises
qui travaillent dans le secteur
aéronautique précisément dans les
entités qui sont majoritairement
musulmane donc c'est une double fête
aujourd'hui et je tiens à la souhaiter à
tous ceux qui sont concernés
et encore une fois plus grand succès
possible à tous les participants de ce
salon aéronautique de moscou
je vous remercie pour votre attention